hi ray I'm actually alleged oh you're a
legend not a legend right okay my badly
misspelled that all right I help me out
their local reaction vs. national
reaction to colin kaepernick as well um
I don't know that it's been radically
different I think most people tend to
agree that he has the right to speak up
and I think part of that is fueled by
the fact that there is no NFL or
organizational rule requiring it after
that it just sort of breaks down on age
and party lines whether what he said as
resonance or not but I think it's not
it's unlike the Barry Bonds thing and
that a Kaepernick is not a guy who is
today helping the 49ers be a great team
so that part of it has sort of been
removed it's more of a how do I feel
about this issue more than that's my guy
saying it so I have to defend him what's
Chip Kelly say Chip Kelly has tried to
keep the ball in the middle of the
fairway for any number of reasons one
you know his you know his history in
Philadelphia was at least slightly
problematic in some eyes secondly Colin
Kaepernick is his second best
quarterback and his first job is to take
care of the football team so he's
basically said you know I respect his
right to sit you know that's not
something I would do or that I think you
know most people in our organization
would do but he's chosen not to make a
public issue of it yet and I think the
reason is clear he can't say with a
straight face that Jeff Driskel or
Christian Ponder are better fits for the
backup job then Colin Kaepernick right
now how often does Kaepernick talk to
the media the accessibility because
normally quarterbacks don't have there's
not that accessibility to be able to
talk to them whenever you want to talk
to them
uh not often um you know I I don't know
that he's uh any more reticent than most
starting quarterbacks in the NFL and I
don't know that Joy's the process very
much but he's not adamantly against it
to the point where he purposely makes
himself unavailable I mean he's more
he's probably slightly more available or
has been in the last year and a half
then he was when he was the starter on a
very good team I have so many questions
for Kaepernick and you know I when did
this happen like did anybody see this
coming what was the inspiration for this
that or a tipping point where where
you've jeopardized your career and I
don't know if he wants to be an activist
and a quarter back or quarterback in an
activist well I don't know that that
that you you can't be either I mean the
fact that nobody else has done it you
know makes makes people wonder but I
don't know that there was like a moment
that said that basically made him become
an outspoken social activist but you
know his twitter feed is Instagram he's
retweeted a number of things along this
line for a while and I think most people
you know saw sort of a gradual
development of this probably over the
last year but there was no linchpin
there was no aha moment that anybody can
point to and until he says there is one
I think we sort of have to take him at
his word on that more interested in what
happens the next game on the road or the
next game at home with Kaepernick well
the next game on the road is the one
he's probably going to play a lot
because it's the fourth exhibition game
that's when the starter you know never
sees the field and Blaine Gabbert is the
starter so Kaepernick and I presume
unless Chip Kelly has something else in
mind we'll get a lot of the snaps it'll
be in San Diego which is a military town
so they'll catch a fair amount of grief
and then the next game after that is the
monday night game at home
against the Rams and I think if you're
looking just for a visceral reaction it
will be greater this thursday then it
will be a week from Monday but it'll be
interesting for the first couple of
weeks and then I think Kaepernick
fatigue will sort of set in and like
every other issue it'll just sort of
fade I was also curious if the
organization or chip kelly just said
look I understand what you're doing but
when we go on to the field we go on as a
team if you go onto the field with us
you're part of a team if you want to
have some kind of protest I go into the
locker room and not be out here for the
anthem that's all I'm asking I you know
if you watch hard knocks you see how
important the anthem is in how to stand
with Jeff Fisher he's instructing his
players how he wants them to stand Chip
Kelly pro-military is that a possibility
that he would say for us and for you
this is what we would like you to do
well he's had three cracks at it and
hasn't done that yet I mean don't forget
that this wasn't the first time that
Kaepernick is sat through the anthem but
this is the first time he noticed that
anybody's noticed yes and it's only the
first time in these warning uniform when
he's done it but if you're a member of
the organization and you want the anthem
to be uniformly you know respected by
standing up he would have been told
something before now and it's pretty
clear that he hasn't been so I have to
assume that this is not as troublesome
to chip kelly as people may be either
would like it to be or would think it
would be and and not every team is
adamant about you know having everybody
stand in line in formation on the on the
sideline for the anthem either so it
really is sort of an organizational
choice and more specifically a coaches
choice and like I said Chip Kelly's had
three cracks to do something about this
if it troubled him and that's troubled
him yet what about Kaepernick's ability
can he still be a borderline great
quarterback because most quarterbacks
who have success build on that success
and he has not it feels like you're not
you know due to injury as well but his
skills have been lessened why
well I think in in in large part the
rosters been lessened it's not as good
at team they have very few weapons and
even during the Harbaugh years it was a
defense-first operation now Kaepernick
when he when he emerged was so unlike
Alex Smith that his skill set probably
jumped out more than maybe it would
normally have but defenses have a much
easier time adjusting to an offense than
the other way around and I think
defenses got enough looks at Kaepernick
that they devised ways to neutralize
what he does well and sort of exacerbate
what he doesn't I think most people
think that he's still not great at going
through his progressions that he fixates
on that first receiver and that if it
doesn't happen he's going to put the
ball under his arm you know and he's at
the stage now where that may never get
fixed but I think when he was with when
he was under Jim Harbaugh and they were
running that offense you know they had
they had this for safety valve of Frank
Gore 25 times a game and it was not a
very intrepid offense in terms of taking
chances it was you know we're going to
get to 20 you're going to get to 10 and
we're going to win time in and time out
and I think that's really sort of the
essence of of the Kaepernick ethos he
was playing for a coach with a very good
offensive coach but a conservative one a
classic big ten offensive coach in a lot
of ways and I don't know that either he
ever made the adjustment from there as
the roster diminished or whether he just
sort of hit his wall quickly he's the
alleged ray Ratto from comcast sportsnet
bay area ray always great to talk to you
we appreciate you getting up for the
program that's why coffee is your best
entertainment value thank you Ray Ray
Rondo the legendary Comcast Sports Net
Bay Area senior insider we don't mess
with junior insiders
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience